ah ah ah o saco de evitar o seu canal no
lixo lixo hills como eu faço o meu canal
e licha
aí eu vou responder muito obrigado pelo
teu comentário espero que moças hoje e
volta à sua vida modo mesmo o lado
pessoal daqui que falar que não sejam
muito bem vindos
é mais um vídeo é mostrado de sacar a
quantia então registrados de que um
vídeo bem diferente como vocês já viram
pelo título hoje nós vamos analisar as
piores construções do mundo mundo num
como vocês sabem eu tenho estudos de
arquitetura portanto eu sei o que vou
fazer com que o jogar eu sei avaliar a
casa civil estava em construir
candidaturas a 3 mil índios com mais um
metro que na quatro vezes dois bem
destruindo boa está bem construída que
este faz coisas pudessem construir tipo
tipo eu escolhi não sair por aí nem tô
de cara e não dá pra ficar apontando
aquelas da câmara do livro branco rio
branco
vamos lá então pessoal primeira
construção e roda o errado
errado tá tudo errado caso não tenha o
espírito para quem só tem uma varanda em
geneva onde matou uma tábua construída
tem uma varanda como janela é baixo não
tá errado e reaproximassem é nesta
imagem nós claramente consegui ver ainda
não sei que aqui temos culpa saí uma
zona pedonal e também de bicicleta não é
o site onde as pessoas podem andar a pé
e de bicicleta e deu um palpite limpa e
rápido e até na estrada tem clima torna
uma certa época que o caso foi
registrado
eu já possa montar o caso caso a multa a
pessoa que construiu está a incentivar
os ciclistas a terem um acidente na q1
paulo há pessoas que gostam de ter
acidente em paula foi garfado senão não
esqueço próxima imagem não funciona
[Música]
próxima imagem para o pessoal para esta
paisagem magnífica fao falta errado e eu
falei bastante evidente falta um pedaço
de pontes as pessoas sobem suas carinha
é cumprida sua vida vão para o seu
trabalho chegou e ainda ponto como se
nada fosse
tá errado e não pode ser assim eu começo
a pensar que as pessoas que constroem
estas coisas que não sei que eles querem
diante já não sei contudo próxima imagem
assim a música aparece aqui pois após
muitas vezes ao fantasma construção
pessoal para encerrar nesta casa
bastante econômica com uma chaminé
dentro da janela uma chaminé dentro da
janela deus mundo
eu vou dizer por que será
era só para dizer que voltar em primeiro
lugar ninguém vai conseguir através da
janela o segundo lugar da chaminé culpa
ou culpa por vai acabar porque se o
vidro eo vidro vai curtir é uma questão
de química meus amigos então só agora tá
frio lá dentro estava envolvido quebra
porque tem tem tem um choque térmico e
cerrado próxima imagem texto
na hora nesta imagem claramente vocês
podem ver um campo de futebol fora de
casa nesta imagem vocês claramente podem
vir um campo de futebol fora degrada
sabe aquela morte uma equipe que quando
vocês têm cinco agrado e pois se vocês
provarem o boi é rápido e vocês ficam
ansiosos querendo buscar em outro lado
não sei se vocês não possui controle
dizer o que vai acontecer isso vai
marcar uma bola no canto e ela passa
província e ficou assim todas as coisas
que o verão é pai para a próxima imagem
nossa imagem muda a posição
isso é que nós podemos ver uma porta uma
porta no meio é adulto uma porta no meio
da corrida você acha que isso abre o
reinado não não desculpa tá a próxima
imagem de cada tipo transição de
plástico mas ele mesmo tem um chinês
está errado tem chinês crescimento ele
foi racista não só do grupo bertin mesmo
eu até culminar o mestre imagem nossa
escola me podem ver uma escada rolante
sem uma das suas casas mesmo por esse
tipo shopping que tem uma escada rolante
que não é ruanda ou seja absoluta
construiu isto construir uma escada um
ano antes em um momento em que a corda
esticada nos aproxima imagem transição
eu nem preciso falar nada nesta né
eu acho que por aqueles que não
receberam nesta porta tenha uma figura
próxima imagem temos aqui um parque
infantil com escorrega com as carinhas
tem uma criança fantástica subir eu sei
lá ela é fantástica até portuguesa com
uma traficante de droga o aí
está o erro escorrega vai dar
directamente mundo para o lado errado
vocês sabem que em parques infantis não
pode segurar porque criança muito bem
todo lado e ela vai querer ela vai
morrer ela vai entrar em coma depois os
pais entrou com um processo em tribunal
para o amor
ela mostra a sua imagem é nessa imagem
vocês claramente podem ver umas trinta e
uma porta e uma carreta e um chão e e
obras absurdas
construiu esta semana num cálculo bem a
distância da porta com o cnt e por isso
não serão ocultadas aquela porta e
estupro e quando eles quiserem importa é
só quando lá fora e consegue ver a
pessoa que tati pagar porque tem um
buraco se tiverem um cão tipo um animal
em casa pode literalmente anunciara
querer sair e ver quem está te pegar
errado e construção errada e não
produtores
então é isso vamos ficar aqui com
espírito para que vocês tenham estado já
sabem só quando comecei aqui do lado
vocês têm visto provavelmente ainda não
viram tanto para ser laranja e aqui em
cima vocês podem subscrever é que o
canal da cufa pessoa fique bem até a
próxima